we do have to update on owen benjamin's
stalker kid i am the goddess and
queen bee versus beg bear how's she
doing
not great what yeah she made a whole
video about the two dollar bill
hello good day happy saint patty's day
everybody
i thought i'd show you this
pp's uh jefferson
pp soft is that what she said like this
looks pretty femme to me for a son
he wrote the constitution of the united
states of america
dude i don't really follow owen
obviously but does anyone have an issue
with thomas jefferson
i don't know i don't think i don't think
she's really going with owen anymore
though it's her own thing
i guess it's her own thing but like i'm
you know i'm gonna guess since you were
a bear ma'am that you probably
are have probably cited the constitution
many many times in your life well
the two constitutional amendments you
know because nobody else
you won two and then you get to three
and i was like
but uh he wrote that he thomas jefferson
was a it was a slave owning
chad who founded the united states of
america thomas jefferson was a slave
owner who wrote all men are created
equal
that's what we call a paradox lady this
is more cat
this is uh they say that this is more
captain america than a two dollar bill
[Laughter]
just trying to you know talk to the kids
ah you slipped in a little reference
there huh
call back a little call back what we in
the business call it call back and the
biz
i don't have time to say business look
at that
wonky eye
[Music]
are you literally trying to why are you
are you shaming a fountain father
are you bullying a dead founding father
are you shaming a founding father right
now hey thomas jefferson nice
wonky eye and he's like yeah i wrote the
constitution
on a two dollar bill
he got [ __ ] didn't he so happy
jefferson really got [ __ ] on the money
from the [ __ ] worst the two dollar
bill isn't he on the nickel or something
too
i don't remember man to be honest
jefferson's on a coin too right isn't it
like
the nickel or something one of those he
got really [ __ ]
paddy's day although to be fair with
inflation the two dollar bill was
probably the original 10
bill you know good point so he
probably was like put me on the two bro
cuz you know what
we have built such an iron foundation
for this country that there's no way
we're going to experience like crazy
inflation there's no way we're gonna get
off the gold standard
there's no way so put me on the two
dollar bill because i'll tell you what
this future in two dollar bills
the lint biscuit album yeah no that's
three dollar bills
i apologize dude mr
benjamin a weenie a weenie
so there's been a mandela effect you've
been man affected by the way ruth
calhoun says two dollar bills rock i
always keep them on me to give kids and
my family
cheap ass christmas gifts can i can i
just tell you how much i
hate people like you i
i hate the two dollar bill gimmick
you've had people give you those before
many times have you ever been happy
about that no
have you ever just went oh great you've
literally now
[ __ ] up my ability to count money in
my wallet now that's all
that's all you do when you do that to
people especially when you you little
prick you probably give them an odd
amount
hey here's three two dollar bills oh
great now i gotta put those off to the
[ __ ] side
and go 5 10 15 20 25 35
45 46 47 48 49
2 4 six i hate that i hate people like
you
it went from green to wean now it's
always gonna be wean
and nothing in between
between the wean and the wing she's
getting crazy
you really stepped into some doo doo
there are lee says uh my dad believes
two dollar bills are bad luck he won't
let them in the house
no it's just that when you were a kid he
was talking about
people and he was just he didn't want
you
to develop what he called habits as him
so he would call them two dollar bills
around
be like listen my daughter comes home
with a two dollar bill
they're both out of this [ __ ] house
and you were just picking up on that as
a kid and you were like
wow dad really hates two dollar bills
hey dad was saying something the other
day about how
he lost his job to a two dollar bill
something about affirmative action
he kept saying something about thirteen
percent of two dollar bills amount for
fifty percent of the currency fraud i
don't know what he meant by that
he said this neighborhood went to [ __ ]
the minute we started letting two dollar
bills in
[Laughter]
a weenie
so watch you're drinking your green
so what is this woman doing besides
showing us all of the money she has
stop rubbing your money in her face oh
the millionaire
showing off her fortune beer b-e-e-r
now b-e-a-r the bears be drinking the
wien beer
freshly squirted
you shouldn't be doing this owen do we
want
let me keep on you what you owe me as an
apology
and others too for what you've done to
them
misleading them taking their money this
journey has cost me thousands of dollars
now because of your misleading
statements
you but you you did this you didn't
allow this to keep going on
you leading people one way and then
lead them with your perversion in
another way that's sick
dude it's really sick
you're encouraging some of this sick
behavior
and i'm willing to bet people have taken
their lives
because you crushed so bad you
yeah you're crushing spirits all right
you're just putting them out of
commission
i'm strong that's why i won't go down
yeah when i look at you i think strong
yeah i'll probably pay for this this is
my wrath
coming out oh boy my biggest sin now
i said it i've been saying it
by the way just some watermelon just
said she's literally gonna come and it
will be awkward
i look we've [ __ ] on owen a lot
on this show whatever but i i'm
pretty confident owen probably owns
firearms
and yeah you don't have to be
particularly proficient you don't have
to be chris kyle
uh if you have a gun in your home to get
out in one piece and then trust me i
think if anything happens and she starts
[ __ ] around if she [ __ ] around i
have a feeling she's going to find out
well this is a little clip here this is
the this is the because she's crazy and
she says stuff but this is
this is the kind of stuff that were i
would be like jesus christ look robot
says
i'm not afraid if anybody wants me to go
to
um to owen's
farm in his little cabin
wait till you see his little cabin
you're gonna be it's gonna blow your
mind if you don't know already
don't go to this man's home
what is wrong with you don't
go to this man's home like i don't
why are people like this
don't go to this man's home
why are people like this a lack of lack
of mental health
real answer well i know but why are like
there's still mental health programs
why isn't like how much of this
behavior do you have to display before
you know this somebody steps in the
state or somebody and says
you're not allowed to be a person for a
while you need to take a time out
and go sit in one of those little fruit
farms until you get your [ __ ] act
together
jesus christ man well you know what that
means and you know what this is inspired
mike there's somebody that's now
stalking us
i have to play the video this is totally
real and not a bit
somebody's talking us
royce i knew right away royce
i gotten your message he actually does
it pretty good i got your message in my
dream royce
rice i'm coming to florida to help you
oh no i'm gonna help you royce
just you you're you're message was
received i know marsh
i know mercy beats you he beats you down
in this
in your house that's fine he's still
coming to save you he beat you down your
house and everyone just watches royce
he wants you to save him by the way no i
don't
but i'm gonna save you and we're gonna
live together
we're gonna have a lot of fun
i i need to be with you royce
i love that he's just filming this the
[ __ ] event like that that is exactly
what it is this is a great video
to be with you royce you're the
reincarnation of my dead uncle
i just i love my dad uncle i gotta make
one
one little uh editor's note here sure
because i'm sure you'll be making more
of it of course
you have to occasionally put your thumb
over the microphone yeah you have to
cover it just for a couple seconds at a
time
every two to three minutes put your
finger over the microphone for like 10
seconds
and it'll make these videos really
[ __ ]
you're the reincarnation of my dead
uncle
and i love my dead uncle oh no
royce i'm gonna save you from
merch and then maybe we can do the show
together
royce no yes i'm gonna save you
don't please don't save me all right
this person needs to make more of these
but you need to make uh
they need to get progressively more
anti-royce and then and you have to
start putting your finger over the
[ __ ]
mic please don't
please don't yeah because royce he's a
liar and i'll tell you right now
he's he's been manipulating people and
[ __ ] royce
no hopefully stop please stop
oh [ __ ] man that's good that was really
well done
i i don't uh i don't disagree i think
royce does want you to save him though
so
please don't come and heal royce